now to the White House where President
Trump was earlier today rallying against
a democratic plan he says would infest
the US with illegal immigrants who would
vote against Republicans the president's
words chief White House correspondent
John Roberts is there again on the North
Lawn
good evening to you Brett and the
president will spend his time up there
on Capitol Hill twisting arms in support
of the - immigration bills that are
there before the house talking with
Republicans tonight about the importance
of getting at least one of those
measures through officially the White
House supports both of them but the
compromise bill is the one that they
would more likely like to see passed the
president saying that these bills or at
least one of them are needed to end the
crisis the families being separated on
the border President Trump will need all
of his deal-making skills to pull this
one off leveraging the horribly
unpopular idea of separating children
from their parents at the border in
order to get Congress to move on
immigration reform as a result of
Democrat supported loopholes and our
federal laws most illegal immigrant
families and minors from Central America
who arrived unlawfully at the border
cannot be detained together the
president is blaming Democrats but it
was his administration's decision to
invoke a zero-tolerance policy at the
border
president Trump insisting that years of
previous White House's not enforcing the
law has had a profoundly detrimental
effect on the nation's roughly half a
million illegal immigrant family units
and minors from Central America have
been released into the United States
since 2014 at unbelievably great
taxpayer expense the president is
pushing Congress to make changes to the
law to allow children to stay with their
parents during the prosecution and
deportation process he also wants a 25
billion dollar commitment to build a
border wall and broader immigration
reforms we want them to come in through
the process through the legal system and
we want ultimately a merit-based
system where people come in based on
merit in a conference call this morning
officials from homeland security in
Health and Human Services said two
thousand three hundred and forty two
children have been separated from their
parents in the month between May 5th and
June ninth they insisted that children
are being well cared for but they
contradicted the DHS secretary who said
yesterday the zero tolerance policy was
not adopted to discourage illegal
immigration we expect that the new
policy will result in the deterrence
effect we certainly hope that parents
stop bringing their kids on this
dangerous journey and entering the
country illegally only 21 the children
removed from their parents are Mexican
but the zero tolerance policy drew an
official response from Mexico's foreign
relations secretary today luis videgaray
calling it cruel and inhumane President
Trump firing back that Mexico is only
too quick to allow migrants from Central
America to pass through Mexico as long
as they are bound for the United States
Mexico does nothing for us you hear it
here they do nothing for us they could
stop it they have very very strong laws
try staying in Mexico for a couple of
days see how long that lasts
the majority of family subject to
separation are from Honduras Guatemala
and El Salvador president Trump today
said in that same speech that he assumed
going to go to Congress for
authorization to withhold US aid from
countries that don't take steps to curb
the flow of illegal migrants Brett John
the White House also had an announcement
on health care today what about that
yeah and this was one that was quite
well received by the National Federation
of Independent Business the body to
which the president was speaking saying
that he is taking steps to authorize
small businesses to band together into
health care associations which will
allow them the purchasing power of
numbers to buy health insurance at much
lower costs listen here for the first
time ever sole proprietors will be able
to come together and buy lower cost
group insurance instead of getting
ripped off by this disaster that we all
know as Obamacare while small businesses
seem to appreciate the effort there are
critics who say that this is going to
lead to substandard health coverage for
people who are in sole proprietorships
or small businesses and only seek to
further weaken Obamacare right we'll
follow all of that and John thank you